-Welcome back. We have a great show tonight, everybody.
But, first, not a lot of things are certain in this crazy world.
We scurry through life lickety-split
from one fleeting experience to another.
Nothing seems sacred anymore. Nothing seems permanent.
And that's why this week at "The Tonight Show,"
we're saluting the one thing we know is still permanent --
the permanent.
A.k.a. the permanent wave. A.k.a. the perm.
That's right, everyone.
It's the return of "Tonight Show" Perm Week!
-♪ It's Perm Week ♪
-♪ On "The Tonight Show" ♪
♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ Oh, my God ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is "Tonight Show" Perm Week,
the very special week where each day we pick one person
from our audience and stylishly perm their hair.
Tonight's lucky perm recipient is Chris Scott.
Chris is 21 years old.
He's from Hampton Bays, New York.
And he's very excited about his new hairdo.
It's been a big day for Chris. Here. Take a look.
-I'm Chris Scott, I'm 21 years old,
and I'm getting a perm today.
I always had short hair, but once COVID happened,
I just let it grow.
The craziest thing I've ever done to my hair --
when I was 11 years old, got my name, "Chris,"
right in the back of my head.
I've never thought about getting a perm before,
but how can I turn this down?
-We're Chris' parents. -I'm his cousin.
-And I'm his girlfriend.
-We can't wait to see Chris with a perm.
-Ever since Chris started growing out his hair,
he's had more confidence.
And I think with a perm, he'll have even more confidence.
-I think he'll look like a ramen noodle soup.
-I think when people see me at work and at school,
people are gonna be a little confused,
but I think it's just gonna make the whole place just --
The whole world's gonna be a better place now.
-Yeah, that's right.
The whole world's gonna be a better place.
[ Laughs ]
I can't wait to see what Chris is gonna look like.
Now, Chris has been sequestered since he got permed,
so he hasn't seen himself yet
and his friends and family haven't seen him, either.
The entire process has been cloaked in secrecy.
We have his family right here. Say hello, guys.
-Hi! -Hi!
[ Cheers and applause ] -Yeah! Whoo!
-How are you? Everything okay? Are you excited about this?
-Super hyped. -Yep. Super excited.
-Yeah, do not take the blindfolds off yet.
But, Mom, you've seen all of Chris' hairstyles
throughout his -- -Yes, I have.
-Yeah. Do you think this is gonna stick?
-I don't know. We'll see how it comes out. I hope so.
-You sounded very confident. Sure. Alright.
You guys in the audience, you guys excited to see
what Chris is gonna...?
[ Cheers and applause ]
You guys ready for the brand-new Chris?!
[ Drum roll ]
Well, here -- Leave your blindfolds on.
Here is Chris before...
and here he is now.
Chris, come on out!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
[ Jimmy laughing ]
-Wow! Wow!
-Hey. How you doing? Amazing.
-Wow. I mean...
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Can you give us a 360 look at this jam?
Oh, yeah. That looks good. That's good.
You look unbelievable. Alright.
Family, are you ready to see Chris?
-We're ready.
-Hold hands, and I'll scoot everyone over.
Alright. Yep. You kind of come with me.
We're getting very, very close here.
-Alright. -Alright.
On the count of "three," take off your blindfolds.
One, two, three.
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it! I love it!
-Are you -- Are you more in love than you were before?
-Oh, my God. -Yeah. Definitely. Definitely.
-What -- You're speechless.
-I -- It's -- It's so puffy. It's puffy.
It's very -- It's very puffy.
-I don't know what it looks like.
-Chris. -You look great, man.
-It's different, but you look good.
-It's great. You look great, man.
-Chris, are you ready to see yourself?
-Oh, absolutely. -Oh, my God.
-It looks great. It looks great.
-You ready? You ready?
Take a look, my friend, and enjoy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Wow.
It's amazing. It's really good.
Can you headbang a little bit? I think -- Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ] I kind of dig it!
-Yeah! It's great.
-Our thanks to the Mark Ryan Salon
for this wonderful perm.
Isn't this amazing?
We're giving out perms every night this week
on "The Tonight Show."
Happy Perm Week, everybody. Stick around.
We'll be right back with Elizabeth Banks. Dude.
-♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ On "The Tonight Show" ♪